j'ai 83 ans et je suis dans le magasin
dans une magasin depuis 1910 que je
vends les chapeaux
non loin de la bonne ville d'Angers dans
le Maine-et-Loire où fut tourné le film
c'est dames au chapeau vert se tient
depuis plus d'un siècle la boutique de
Mademoiselle Adèle aujourd'hui
chapelière en rupture de commerce
ici mademoiselle Adèle nous sommes dans
une chapellerie dans un musée
avait monté ce magasin peut-être vers
180 68
alors
1870 moi je suis venu ici pour d'abord
vendre dans les chapeaux en 1910 voilà
j'ai commencé à 1910 avant de les
chapeaux dans cette chapellerie en
pénétrant dans votre boutique
mademoiselle vallée on a l'impression
que le temps s'est arrêté qu'on est
passé brusquement 80 ou 100 ans en
arrière plus que ça voyez-vous c'est
toutes les coiffures qu'il y a dans le
magasin en plus de 100 ans sont toutes
plus âgés que toi malgré que je ne suis
plus jeune et par exemple ce préfixe que
nous voyons marquer
bien avant moi pour la bonne raison que
Bono il voulait pas que les ses clients
marchands parce que les gens riches
marchandaient plus que les pauvres
malheureux
[Musique]
alors un bon chapeau pour aller aux
courses
vous connaissez pas ça il est de quelle
époque celui-là
les toutes petites communes ils sont
inscrites
est-il un délicat de vous demander votre
âge mademoiselle
j'ai 83 ans et je suis dans le magasin
dans un vieux magasin depuis 1910 que je
vends les chapeaux mais il y en a aucun
de rester dans le magasin que j'ai vendu
depuis combien de temps voulez-vous plus
vendre vos chapeaux depuis 10 ans que
j'en ai plus avant de ce que je vendais
c'est devenu une collection maintenant
tous les mercredis plus des clients que
quand je vendais de 50 à 60 personnes
des paquets d'épicerie de chez mon frère
là et d'ailleurs et puis les
petits-enfants pendant que les mamans
vont faire leurs courses c'est souvent
cela à s'amuser avec des poupées
c'est ça la vie du vieux temps et du
jeune temps en faisant dans votre
collection il y a aussi les outils
il fallait les outils pour reformer les
chapeaux on faisait bouillir l'eau il y
avait un petit croisillon et nous
mettions le chapeau à la vapeur pour
pouvoir arriver à en faire ce que l'on
voulait
et ses cordes servaient à quoi ces
Filson ses cordes
c'était pour refaire les bords
voyez-vous avec un fer de 5 kg de nez
comme ça
quand le chapeau était tout près à la
vapeur on en faisait ce que l'on voulait
et puis quand c'était tout à la vapeur
tout mouillé en prenait le l'histoire
pour le refroidir et ça je sais voilà
dans le vieux temps et vous même
mademoiselle Adèle vous ne faisiez pas
que vendre
tous les chapeaux à la vieille machine
que vous voyez
mais c'est une collection très rare que
vous avez là je crois et puis ça c'est
un avaloir alors il avalait quand on
voulait faire le neuf chapelier qui
était sur la forme
voyez-vous
voilà chapeau sur la peur on faisait 9
chapelier
et puis avec la valveur comme il était
en haut et ben fallait descendre pour
pouvoir faire le lien du chapeau alors
avec la valoir
et puis avec le fer s'il y avait des
plis alors comme le chapeau était tout
bout on en faisait à peu près ce que
l'on voulait mais pas tout de suite
parce qu'au départ le client choisissait
son chapeau et ensuite on lui mettait à
la forme de sa tête à la dimension de sa
tête
de feu se met à la tête du client
le mot le chapeau mou
on vendait déjà la tête du client à
l'époque ah oui de tout le temps
de tout le temps la tête du client alors
pour bien lustrer mon chapeau mon beau
chapeau virtuel
c'est un coup de main oui il fallait
l'avoir il fallait du métier il fallait
avoir travaillé le chapeau et du chapeau
et puis maintenant je vais vous faire
voir ça ça s'appelle un bichon vous le
saviez peut-être pas non c'est pour
bichonner les chapeaux et voilà alors
maintenant le chapeau mécanique allez
une deux et trois
dans l'autre sens le voilà le chapeau
claque vous le refermez
c'était un coup à prendre aussi
combien encore
moi non plus je peux pas tu viens de
quoi s'agit-il qu'est-ce que vous nous
proposez maintenant
des vieilles coiffes qui ont du siècle
dernier
[Musique]
bon bah mademoiselle Adèle on va vous
quitter mais juste avant j'ai retenu
celui-là qui me plaît vraiment
énormément alors si vous voulez je vous
le prendre voilà si je vous l'achète
vous me faites le prix que vous voulez
je vous le prends tenez
je vais rien du tout mais je vous le
vends pas comment ça se fait écouter une
plaie énormément ça fera juste un vous
en reste au moins des centaines
[Musique]
les collections ça ne se vend pas on
garde tout et voilà
voilà
[Musique]